So there's this inherent conflict in the system though,...
...which is: Are we trying to optimize News Feed to give each person, all of you guys,...
...the best experience when you're reading?
Or are we trying to help businesses just reach as many people as possible?
And in every decision that we make, we optimize for the first,...
...for making it so that the people who we serve, who use Facebook,...
...and who are reading News Feed get the very best experience that they can.
And that means that if a business is sharing content that's gonna be useful for them,...
...then we'll show that.
But that means if the business is sharing content that isn't gonna be useful for them,...
...we may not show that.
Because it's probably more important that they learn about their friend...
...who had a baby and their baby is healthy.